في بعض الاشجار شهيقه الارتفاع بماليزيا
يعيش نوع من النمل يسمى قلوببسيس هذا
النمل يدافع عن نفسه بطريقه غريبه جدا
فيقوم بغرس الفك السفلي الذي يحتوي على
خزان صغير يصنع فيه ماده كيميائيه صفراء
اللون تحتوي على ماده لاصقه كالصمغ هذه
الماده تقوم بشل حركه الضحيه ثم تفرز
سائلا ساما جدا لكن ماذا لو كان العدو
اكبر حجما من هذه النمله في هذه الحاله
نرى اغرب شيء على الاطلاق النمل يفجر نفسه
من اجل حمايه الاخرين لذا سماه العلماء
النمل الانتحاري فهو يضغط على اعضائه
الداخليه ويعصر نفسه حتى ينفجر وتنتشر
الماده الصفراء والاكثر غرابه ان من يقوم
بتلك العمليات الانتحاريه هم افراد النمل
الاكبر سنا بسبب قله انتاجاتهم فهم يفضلون
الموتى من اجل الاخرين
[موسيقى]